so this is our second of whatever this
is is this your podcast sure or is this
an ibel
this is a original able
slash on slash jordan shelby collab okay
i like that i just have no idea what i'm
doing and also we've done this once
before
and i never
like saw i kind of like
it if we would just if we just do these
podcasts i never see them again it kind
of feels cool but are you gonna post the
first one i would like to yeah
eventually it'll happen because
otherwise it ruins the illusion of what
we're doing here because the whole time
i'm doing it i'm thinking oh this is
going out so if i don't do that i'm not
honoring myself
and my my past self and you guys are all
about honor right
then you know what podcasters yeah
podcast
yeah we're very honorific bunch yeah 100
okay i i just i feel like we said some
things
that maybe we shouldn't have i don't
remember what it was but i remember it
being a lot it was going on yeah it was
nerve-wracking for sure anyway that'd be
cool if we released this first
yeah that way people have no idea what
we're talking about yeah
um but yeah i mean it's just like a
snapshot into our lives and the kind of
emotions and thoughts that are going
inside her head recorded it's beautiful
yeah
it's out there yeah yeah so you're
concerned about this haircut that you
have right now yeah i mean i did it
myself so i'm sort of more of a critic
okay of it but if someone else does it
i'm like oh you don't like it it's not
really it's someone else's handiwork
it's like someone if you don't like a
picasso it's not really my fault yeah i
mean usually because if someone else did
that you can say a professional did it
yeah what's your opinion compared to
theirs yeah that rocks yeah but since i
did it on my own head it's like a
hundred percent it's my fault but it is
even
if it was shittier it's more impressive
that you did you can get away with a
shittier haircut if you tag it with
i did this yeah maybe if you sign it on
the back
yeah people won't comment just stamp it
yeah it's like a organic uh whatever
like a organic lemonade you're like oh
it doesn't taste as good but it was made
organically yeah they're complete it's a
different
it comes from slack yeah so it's like oh
it's not as good but although it's
ethically sourced lemonade probably
tastes better than regular lemon
whatever yeah what's something organic
that tastes worse
um i don't i think theoretically it
should always taste better
it should look shittier
yeah and taste better something homemade
yeah it's like that looks bad but the
inside is
yeah delightful it's more authentic it's
not made of high fructose corn syrup
right but that does taste good
hfcs
if you could put high fructose corn
syrup in something that was organic it
would make it even better
it's american msg yeah it's organic and
then we added hyper
and we made it awesome
it's like but it still is organic yeah
except
yeah yeah cool so what have you been
doing lately well i just want something
i want to be very quickly move past your
haircut that quickly i do think it's
good i know i think it makes your head a
little bit longer but i think it's good
you're pulling off well the head is as
long as it is so the head is as long as
you make it yeah you know if i'm
revealing more length then it's really
my head's fault your head is as long as
you want it to be
heads are constructs head sizes are just
made up by society
um what's going on with me comedically
lately
there was uh the moon tower comedy
festival you were in it no
but it was you were watching here and my
roommate's heavily involved in it so i
just basically follow him around a
little bit but i wasn't even in town for
the first part
um you watched a lot of i just want i
wanted to watch his audition and jump
around oh jfl was here dude there was
the jfl edition which it's so fun every
comedy audition
it's the most comedy thing ever it's
just in the worst environment
even if it's if it's if there's an
edition of the club the crowd's probably
gonna suck if it's at a bar
yeah i mean with a comedy show there's
the illusion that it's the best comedy
thing happening ever but with an
audition you're like oh this is like a
preparation for something that's going
to be awesome later
and so no one wants to go there and be
like oh this is like a slightly shittier
version of what some other people
a better audience is going to enjoy well
i actually think i think they're too i
think i think comedians
talk about how shitty situations are too
much actually kind of as a side note
like i think usually the audience
doesn't know that they suck when they
sit up and if you don't tell them that
they suck then they're just going to
continue having a good time and not
really knowing
what the bar is for it could have been
that yeah
and i think
we at comics get down on themselves a
lot or just get in their heads and they
they tell the audience they're having a
bad time when they're not and then they
start having a bad time
but i but for auditions
presumably auditioning for someone who
knows
how funny
uh what the highest level like what how
hard people can laugh and like what a
good comedy situation is like and i
think even experts it's kind of hard to
tell like if
you see a good comedian bomb yeah for
your first time even if you're really
good at cut really
you know you have a lot of comedy
information and experience i don't i
don't know how easy it is to make a
determination on how good they are if
you get example anyway i just every
comedy audition i see is is in a
terrible situation which is kind of
hilarious and kind of perfect for yeah
that way if you really succeed then you
deserve it
yeah they're gonna make you work for it
yeah and it builds the skills and
whatnot but yeah
i think it's like when the they know
it's an audition they're like oh we're
supposed to be judging them oh the the
judges are judging them let me judge the
audiences yeah yeah so they're not
purely just
experiencing it they're analyzing it
right which is
involved uh related to the lighting that
they say in comedy shows
too right like if it's too bright then
they're not just experiencing it they're
thinking about what they look like and
what the people around them look like
and this podcast is sponsored by red
bull
are you just sneaking in
things into this sorry i'm sponsored by
red bull and they hire me to go to
various stardust this is like a movie
theater yes you're sneaking in food 100
no i love red bull i think a lot of
people use it uh to get energy
or the illusion or for wings energy
but i've never really experienced that
i'm i'm never like i need more energy
i'm just like this is the energy i am
and i'm not gonna have more
i'm just gonna that is your energy
my energy is no energy it's just [ __ ]
level
yeah and i've seen you like you know
like be level and then you'll
smoke weed or
juice drink or something and then you'll
stay
it won't affect
your energy yeah interesting
i'm trying to maintain
i'm doing everything i can maintain what
whatever energy level is my default you
don't get you don't feel the effects of
coffee
i do i don't drink that much of it
though so it's not an everyday thing for
me yeah that's good
you get so addicted to it did i'm still
stuck on movie theater for some reason
did your mom ever sneak in
did you sneak in food into the movie
theater no really yeah i just didn't eat
i don't have to eat all the time
so he's kind of backhanded but
[Laughter]
you did that you snuck in like well no i
was gonna say i think that's a mom thing
maybe it's uh
i uh maybe i was gonna say maybe i
couldn't see an asian mother doing this
but i also could just like
yeah smuggling snacks in like here can
you hold this
yes kimchi sandwiches and stuff but yeah
that's not really movie theater food no
chopsticks or not movie theater
well it depends on what country you're
in
it well if you go to are they using
chopsticks and movie theaters
yeah in asia are they like moving like
food in general is very subjective right
but are they giving you bowls of rice in
asia
like that doesn't seem practical even if
it's
culturally but what about like bags of
[ __ ] that you have to open up and then
it's crinkly that doesn't seem very
practical
or
the mechanics
of
get grabbing uh which they don't usually
do potatoes but like you can grab
popcorn right it'd be like eating
popcorn with a foot
well you don't have to use chopsticks
for dumplings
right
sure but i'm saying chopsticks would be
hard in a movie theater uh yeah i guess
so
not a lot of utensils
um but yeah i mean
uh asians uh probably
prior frugal so they might do that they
might sneak stuff in
um but yeah i mean maybe it's a motherly
thing to do where they're like i need to
take care of my child provide them
nutrients
yeah but your mom didn't do that
no your mom was like and we will not eat
anything it wasn't a policy it was just
you tried to take stuff and she was like
[ __ ] it's just how it shook out
but you uh you snuck in stuff in the
movie theaters yeah it's a big thing for
my mom my mom's very
of maternal i guess so she always wants
to be feeding what is why would she
sneak in
just like way too much [ __ ]
like way too much [ __ ] did she ever get
caught
i i
don't remember probably one time but i
do remember the feeling of being young
and going through the movie into the
like through the movie security and her
being like this
yeah hold this tuna sandwich like wyatt
yeah yeah good time
yeah um
tuna sandwich that's
that would be terrible to take
yeah i mean
uh
how's my comedy life going how's your
comedy life doing you're doing crazy
[ __ ] i'm sure you've talked about it on
podcast already yeah right uh-huh did
you talk to um
ali about it allie mack yeah wikowski no
i uh saw her briefly yesterday i don't
know her very well but i know you guys
have both been in that role of yeah
opening those arenas out yeah i'll have
to ask her i totally didn't even realize
that's something i could ask her i only
saw her for a little bit before it
killed tony yesterday
and then she had to jet but
i mean that's a yeah it's a it's i feel
like it's a very specific experience
that you guys have both yeah done we
could we could bond over it i'd be
interesting to hear you guys compare
notes about
what it's like because i've been to
arena shows like that and seen the first
comedian when people are still seating
and whatnot is that when you would go up
basically like the last little bit of
fort worth yeah but for jacksonville i
think everyone was pretty much seated
yeah it's interesting
yeah
it's a weird role it's like a [ __ ]
event as opposed to a show
yeah
the craft of taking a bullet in an arena
yeah because it's such a grand
setting but yeah the role is the worst
role yeah but it's still like better
than not being on it at all an opener in
an arena is better than a headline
a headliner is a club interesting yeah
there is something that i said or they
said at another podcast where it's like
if 5 000 people laugh in a 12 000 people
arena then that's a bomb
so even if you get 5 000 people to enjoy
your joke it's not enough i would think
about it in the opposite way where it's
like you don't have to get if 5 000
people laugh out 12 000 it's still going
to sound really good like get some
pressure off yourself because how many p
what percentage of the audience do you
think is laughing
when you make
on average if you make a joke and let's
say we say that joke did well
how much
of the audience thing actually laughed i
would say 60
like not
near 100 though right just
a a majority yeah
and then everyone else is just like whoa
everyone's laughing that must be funny
yeah they think it's funny well they're
just sitting there smiling and not them
being quiet yeah but it's not it's hard
to like
you never see
just
laughing laughing about it's always a
mix yeah you know but five that the
point being five thousand out of 12
doesn't sound like a bomb
well depends on how loud
you would know
i mean it's like
uh
yeah i mean i think that there are times
when a lot of people do laugh at the
same time doesn't matter how loud they
look
if it's just a chuckle
yeah that would be funny if they're all
laughing very quietly
they're all smiling someone else gets
one person to laugh much louder
sounds like they're doing better it's a
different kind of art form because in
plays you don't want anyone making any
noise you're just like that was great i
killed it and all you have to do is like
you know it was so quiet
yeah there's no
you could hear a pin drop yeah there's
no feedback system for acting live like
that yeah
that's why they're so delusional because
you have to motivate yourself through
your own mind
that would be
great though if we can invent a system
of feedback like a silent system of
feedback maybe just a remote or
something so that they could see in the
back but wouldn't measure how good they
were acting based on how emotional
everyone yeah i got a 7.9 on the jordan
shelby scale yeah
but what am measuring it change the
the the experience for the audience
because now they're thinking about it
instead of just
being there i guess it would be like how
much am i being affected by yeah but i
just
i don't care i think i think it would be
funny to be acting really heartfelt and
emotional like you're saying and you
look up and you're getting [ __ ] three
out of ten
audiences hating it
yeah and then there's people that
despite performances that are like you
think i'm bad i'll show you bad
maybe that's why they have all these
[ __ ] award shows for acting yeah not
really for comedy because like we
already get
have you ever like calculated your
laughs
or like catalogued your sets or done
anything analytical towards your comedy
um
not in like processing the results like
that which is what i think you mean i'm
pretty analytical in
how i am creative like i'm not like fun
i'm not a fun creator
i'm a very like
edit like
type a sort of creative person
but i i in in processing the results
i'll
i'll like take notes or listen to the
record but i'm not i'm not counting like
how many times they laughed in like the
laugh per minute yeah like i might do
that
calculation i also wouldn't want to know
it's not really my game like my game i'm
trying
hopefully it's more quiet for a while
and then bigger laughs yeah as opposed
to just
a regular speed right
you're all about the feel
like i do a lot of silence i feel like
so yeah
i probably would not
get good results
yeah i'm a comedian that specializes in
silences that's honestly a very douchey
thing to say i feel like that controls
the silence so well i don't think i do
but i just talk slowly yeah you draw
them in yeah i try and
yeah you're not quite going out there
getting them which is like
kind of desperate and sad sometimes
you let them come to you unless you have
to like doing that in situations they're
all here listening like you don't have
to
they already got to but
some people like the illusion that oh
[ __ ] we just happen to walk in and this
guy's yelling at us and we have to pay
attention i don't know i have to do that
in gnarlier shows some of the shows like
bar shows and stuff like that i have to
the animal shows be loud circuses yeah
just scream to get their attention but
they're all paying attention though yeah
don't you think the ceiling is higher
if they're all listening and then you
can take them where you want to as
opposed to you have to get them and then
take them somewhere
well
i think they're different
somewhat different art forms actually
people talk about stand up there's
actually two kinds of stand up there's
stand up where you have to earn
everyone's attention and then hold it
and there's stand up where you already
have everyone's attention and then you
can take them where you want to and they
require different skills but don't you
think one's better than the other well
the second one where everyone has you
already have everyone's attention is
stand up that's what the art form is
actually yeah and because it it's just
that's what it's in it's an ideal form
what you should be able to do that's
what stand-up is but you'll suck at that
if you aren't forced to do the other one
first but you gotta learn the other one
first when you're starting out when
you're the newest and the worst at
comedy you have to like it's so paid so
big yeah but um
but it's not actually
stand up like there's
distinctly things you can't do in those
situations i think it's more carnival
barking or like emceeing or like yeah
you know just wrangling people which is
fun and some people are really great at
it and it's cool to see but
it's harder to take them on fancy
thought experiments and right impart
better ideas in their head you just have
to go for the basics right which is the
kind of in some ways the highest form of
stand-up but
yeah you don't get those you don't get
to practice it in those situations but
it's easier in some it's just yeah i
don't know
yeah i mean i think that we're both of
the second type
and not the first type so maybe we're
just
uh
being uh you know
partisan about it but i think uh
the first kind of sucks the first kind
it sucks but it's necessary and i think
it's good to go back to every once in a
while
but it's just if once you get to a
certain level you the progress is all in
the
second kind yeah right yeah because you
want to
excel in an arena or in an area where
uh
you have the
the where what that's what it's going to
be like people are going to come once
you succeed at the first kind it's
eventually going to turn into the second
kind yeah so you might as well get good
at that instead of getting good at the
first card well yeah but
what's interesting is that i i
i also think that um
or i think that some people nowadays
just because of how the internet works
you can
headline with no experience like as long
as you can sell the tickets you're going
to get those spots as a comedian and it
doesn't matter on your experience and so
you can start
jumping to that sec you could start in
that second kind of stand-up now where
everyone's already there and excited yes
i do think those people are [ __ ] right
i think they're completely [ __ ] yeah i
think accumulatively you will get more
stage time because of your fame that
will allow you to develop and you will
get funnier but i think unless you you
have to pass through the yeah or else
you don't know what's actually funny you
just know what the audience wants to
hear
yeah and you know you don't your bar is
lower like what you think is a crushing
joke actually isn't because you haven't
had to pressure test it for six people
yeah
that's why we're about we're the best
that's why we're the best comedians
[Music]
so what do you think about elon musk
buying twitter
um
i don't really know
i don't really know i'm not like i like
that
like i'm
i don't really know i think yeah sort of
good sort of bad here is my
full take on it basically is
that ends with i don't know
right is that
there used to be
this
theory this term called the public space
right
and it's a like philosophical idea
that
um we
was integral in some ways to
what we uh
the laws we based our country on like
they had this idea of the public space
and what freedom should be available how
important it is when they
created our country and in governments
in general and it's carried this entire
time
since the beginning of the country until
now and then just since the 90s than
just 30 years ago
or whatever since the internet came
around in in in the modern sense now the
public space changed and now it's online
and we haven't
caught up to that right it's a new area
yeah there's this core idea that has
manifested itself in our in in
our government and our lives for
hundreds of years in this way and then
just recently it's like okay and now
it's over here and we're just catching
up to that and i think
we need to catch up to that and it's
it's very important
and
buying twitter is a part of that
but i
don't know good bad how we fix it
yeah well
i that's all i got right
i mean i but i know it is
i kind of think
it definitely happened we know that for
sure
which is the one thing we can all agree
on it's the only thing we can agree on
is that it happened it did pretty sure
happened
yeah i heard about it on twitter
yeah what do you think about it um i
mean i think that
they might come here what if twitter
comes here
to oh cause he lives here now right
i mean i don't know if america was all
about public spaces because it seems
like it was for private ownership like
every piece of land was private i don't
think of like america as like a place
with a lot of public stuff i guess
public land is a thing and like
bureau land management land and national
parks so maybe but
um i just feel like the internet was
more free
than
our
1980s american public was and then we
were like holy [ __ ] this thing is free
and amazing and beautiful let's pollute
it and taint it with our corporations
and our profit driven motives
and i think that um
twitter is uh
i i just don't i mean that's what our
system is like we have to have rich
people that are awesome that do
the right thing and it's really tricky
to rely on rich people to do the right
thing well that's because
it sucks that we have to yeah because
that's our whole system is built around
one person getting rich and then they
get to do whatever they want in society
and everyone else just has to take it
and hope they can be rich one day
that is pretty cool that's how it is and
that's how our forefathers picture right
well two things one just to just uh as
claire to clarify when i say public
space i don't necessarily not for you
just in general i mean public land i
mean like the theoretical idea that
there was always a town square where you
could go to and
crazy [ __ ] you can go into the public
square and say this and just yell
blasphemous [ __ ]
yeah or say whatever you want and the
the
say the public space it's the laws
regulating that public space so yes you
can screen whatever you want but if you
whip your dick out we don't allow that
and there's this all this interplay with
it right it's now online to fix it my
main thing with elon musk i think it's
funny that
um
just he's just so divided it's people
love him or hate him
um i think it's funny that
people be like i hate elon musk
justified or not like they can't even
boycott him it's like you can't even
afford
what he's selling like you can't boycott
him because it's not even for you
he doesn't need you tweet about it but
you can't even not
use the products that he's doing that's
so crazy he's the richest guy in the
world and he's selling things to like
five percent of the population that's
sad honestly
and he has this whole thing was like
we're going to get the cost down it's
like no we're actually just going to
keep the cars dope and expand expensive
so do what do you think about the
twitter mob do you
agree with them or disagree you think
that they should exist or shouldn't
like blue haired
transgender just like the idea of the
twitter mom
well that's a little bit because that's
there's the twitter mob and then there's
far left twitter because the mob can be
either side right
you just mean groupthink on twitter
yeah
i mean i think at this point it's
what i went over side politically it's
um
bad i mean i just the death of nuance
and
compassion for other people in a lot of
ways
um my problem with the left side of the
twitter mob is that they uh
yeah
well i used to like what i used to think
was cool about being a progressive
person or a part of it was the the um
yeah the compassionate the like radical
compassion element of it and
that seems to be gone
it seems to be full of hate and vitriol
and and um they've soured judgment yeah
they got cranky yeah but i don't blame
them because the opposition is so is
abhorrent evil yeah i think the other
side is nazi's apparently yeah at least
back in the 70s and 60s that they were
like well we just want to have a nice
civil
time and you know we're defending
suburban lifestyle but now they're just
like we don't need they've lost all
pretense they're just like this is
solely for
like
ethno state monogamy yeah it's not it's
not um and it's like how often do you
have to debate people and whether black
people deserve to have basic human
rights or not right before you're like
okay i'm going to stop listening to the
you
um but you know
i think that's like how long can you
intelligently debate someone i think
yeah yeah i think the left has just
turned into
using the tactics that the conservatives
used because they've argued with them so
long
they're just turned into conservatives
and they're the left
is using the same tactics conservatives
in some ways yeah because it just
politics work like that in general right
you go so far one way all of a sudden
you're on the other side
yeah and i don't think that uh we need
to be expanding our gender
uh idea of gender that much i just feel
like most people are man or woman and
it's not an area that's fruitful to keep
like keep uh
thinking about
well yeah i mean i think
there are a couple parts of that i think
that uh
we
i think there is validity to the
obviously it's extremely important also
i think there's validity to the
criticisms where it's like it is not as
important
uh in term
in terms of proportionally the attention
and resources that we're giving to it
that there are potentially other people
in in more dire conditions that could
use our help and it would be uh help
more people
in in a greater way but we're just
focusing on
on this one thing
um
the transgender thing is so it's so
triggering to
um
but no i think the main issue i
unfortunately i think there are some
i think that rich
good intended good intending affluent
wealthy white kids have taken a
issue of transgender rights which is
very important but primarily related to
people of
color
transitioning in low-income households
and the fact that they're like
suicide rate
and rate of them getting kicked out of
their house is absolutely [ __ ] crazy
and like that's the trans issue
but the media just picks up stories of
college kids
wearing wristbands like you have to call
me this now and those are the stories
that they're picking up and it
completely [ __ ]
the
the actual core issue there which is
actually almost never discussed uh
that's a distraction
they use it as a distraction so the left
and the right so that they don't
actually have to make any economic
sacrifices
yeah no one's it's
yes
yeah i think i would agree with that the
the culture war in general seems to be
very
uh
distract like
yeah intentionally distracting in some
ways
yeah i mean that's the goal of it
so that we don't actually
fight the
rich
and take their money
but um
what do you think about communism
i think that communists should have to
use the bathrooms of their gender
[Laughter]
they should have a separate bathroom for
communists so they can clean it up
themselves
equally um what do we think about
communism yeah
and what
like modern like silverlight communism
or like well it seems like it's the
alternative to capitalism is that the
only alternative or
do we need a mix of both
i don't
i don't know i don't know if there is
an alternative to capitalism a
functional alternative to
capitalism even though capitalism
is kind of broken nowadays but
i i don't i'm just not smart enough to
like know what
and to actually find it
that whatever kind of government is
actually most beneficial to whatever
kinds of people you just we haven't been
able to run enough tests
you know there's the one former it's
just
it's not like we gave it a good shot
it's not like we're gonna have two
separate things you can't double blind
like test every it's just like that's
the way it is let's see how it works out
yeah and like when people did try
communism it's not like we left them
alone to see if it would work
no and i don't communism should be tried
first
on like a small island and then you can
scale it up and then you can scale it up
you shouldn't just start with china you
know it's like there's a lot going on
there it would be better if you
uh were aware of the issues you were
going to run into aka it'd be coming out
i mean oliver i don't even know what
china is china is like
i think they're supposed to be communism
but i don't know how their government
works
i don't know what the politburo how they
have people in there and like with the
u.s you know the supreme court and the
executive branch and the legislative but
then with china it's like i don't know
why
yeah it's just china we're china and our
government is china
chinese all the way through no i think i
think the answer is actually it's kind
of [ __ ] up
that i think we're all just like yeah
it's a dictatorship and there might be a
genocide but just
who knows let's not talk i think we're
uh
aware of what could be happening but no
one just wants to look at it directly in
the face we're just
yeah moving on with our
global lives yeah you know
so do you think we should try to be
funnier or do you think we're doing a
good job
like you and me right now definitely
america
i think america should be funny
do you think we should be funnier yeah i
mean we just elected donald trump that's
the funny issue
as a country we went a whole full [ __ ]
we elected donald trump and we stand
under the g7 where he fell asleep like
a cartoon character
yeah they're like real issues happening
in our guys
that's
well yeah i mean i think that we haven't
produced a good comedy movie in a long
time
i think that we're stagnating well
no it will because all of the
people say that with comedies now it's
or with movies in general it's either
uh
five million dollar indie film or a 200
million dollar marvel movie there's not
there's nothing in the middle in any
anymore and what was in the middle
before used to be high budget comedies
like apatow talladega nights sort of
like big comedies or will feral comedies
so you think it's like an economic thing
because of pirating and the internet
like people don't know
how to make money off of movies so it's
either like you have no money or you
have
giant uh huge blockbusters
no yeah i think it's just an originality
problem in that there in the end the
movie industry is businesses in charge
of art in in this weird in charge of the
art that is created because they have
the tools to create it and their
businesses run
risks so that they've just
as time has gone on they've become more
and more risk-averse i guess not like we
know spider-man likes movies so we're
just going to keep making these
spider-mans and then this little thing
costs nothing so we'll give it a shot
and maybe it will be a big hit i think
it's mostly just
so from my experience like working in
that industry oh right because you're
working the business
yeah
i've had some a little bit behind the
current things and and you know it's
just you know they're not it's a t and t
hbo is 18 t it's they're just trying to
make money so they don't give you
not the best way to make movies is just
be driven by money
i don't know i think that's why they are
there's no high budget comedies anymore
it's because they're too
risky but what about the 80s and 90s
wasn't that the same kind of mentality
then and yet they were making movies
comedy movies yeah i mean maybe i'd have
to look at exactly what happened was
there some big bombs that happened i
don't know why the
it wouldn't be related to comedy
specifically i would think i forget why
the industry has been moving in that
direction
recently
all i know is that it is happening but
i'm not too sure what is what has
sparked it but
i think there's like a
lack of uh
vision or a lack of humor or lack of
hope in our society
i think yeah the iraq war really [ __ ]
us up it's also weird that anyone you
talk to who's like our age nowadays it's
just like yeah it's all over in 50 years
just chilling we're like why do we all
think
everyone is just like and why are we all
okay with it we're all just like yeah
it's a it's the the um how casually you
could and how
wide leap referred to the idea is it's
pretty nuts yeah they were all just
happily holding hands and knowingly
walking into the end of the earth and no
one cares that's what's going to happen
hopefully i get enough jewel pods to
last me till then yeah
that would
be a big deal would you want to see the
wave coming
of the nuclear blast or the asteroid or
would you just want to be asleep
um
i would want to
you know like a lot of my life has been
asleep i haven't experienced demise
coming at me i'd want to experience
you know that rush
whatever that is
the biggest high
just to do some dmt right before
i don't i feel like i would want to be
very
sober for that it does scare me a little
bit the idea of dying well very
intoxicated i don't know why at least no
one will be having more fun than us
if we all die
yeah well
if we all die then you're not missing
out on anything
yeah there's no fomo yeah or if the
world's over yeah kim kardashian isn't
on a yacht she's dead dude yeah don't
worry about what she's doing we're all
in the same boat yeah
yeah well maybe would have saved us in
that situation but
or a submarine yeah
i wonder if the submarine is the
smartest thing to be in
for uh it's either the smartest or the
dumbest well it would make sense
i
wow
i'm about to talk so far
it's
crazy let's see let me tell you a
submarine
in the situation of a park it may it
seems like i've never been in a summer
i think i've stood on top of one really
like at a museum
okay yeah i think i might have done that
it sounds like a field trip yeah
i might have seen it in a movie yeah
um
no doesn't it feel like the shock
absorption of a submarine deep under the
ocean when like something happened so
the earth would be better
than i don't know
because i know like in a bomb like the
thing that kills a lot of people is the
air
pressure yeah or something
and in a water in water it's more uh you
know a viscous
so that might be even more compounded oh
yeah with the the wave
yeah maybe more damage the forces would
be larger
but really i have no idea it depends on
what kind of arm to get into if it's
like a meteor it might boil the water
preferred armageddon
uh
for me or uh to die in or to survive in
okay
most
fun
to die in yeah but then the one
that you think you have the best shot of
making a life
i would say the one i have the best shot
of surviving would be like a nuclear
bomb because then i just have to go into
like you know
utah or like wyoming
somewhere they wouldn't bomb
right but you're not gonna know that i
would maybe because we're in texas we
have a good
opportunity to survive surviving we're
not on a coast and i don't think there
any nuclear style is here we're so
spread out too you need like a bunch of
bombs to kill all of us yeah it would
have if we're going in a nuclear blast
probably the rest of the states is also
completely but it would be a pain in the
ass to survive a nuclear holocaust
because you'd have to have a geiger
counter everywhere you go yeah you'd
have to get out out like you'd have to
go to a different continent yeah i guess
um but you're saying odds wise you think
that's what would be that yeah because
you can just sort of like dodge it like
get in a car
i would think but the worst would
probably be like a meteor yeah you're
gonna hear that really high pitched like
whistling of the bomb dropping you know
so you'll have time though
yeah i don't know why anyone dies in a
nuclear bomb that's what they should
have done in nagasaki you hear that
[Music]
yeah hopefully i'll have enough time
what were you saying then the most fun
would be what uh the most
quick would be a meteor just bam it's
over that's the one you would
prefer to see it'd be the best to die in
you wouldn't want to take your shot at
it like a zombie apocalypse or a
world war three
sort of situation zombie apocalypse
might be fun
if i'm
if i want to do survival
stuff
have a you know have a lot of weapons
and be a badass doesn't even have to be
a zombie apocalypse but just like the
crumbling like watching society crumble
into a free-for-all you know yeah
i think that's what everyone is
sorry
i was just getting turned on by all this
talk of armageddon
um yeah but i think that might be
interesting probably horrific and
terrible but
it would be it's a
very like video game you sort of ooh
will i survive this everything crumbles
are you like
nuclear sounds really bad
yeah it sounds
it's the fallout yeah dying of like
yeah having your arm fall off slowly and
shut not being able you have no agency
in fixing any of it yeah at least if
someone's trying to
iodine with a pet you can you know what
to do yeah it's more of newtonian
physics you have something to do
yeah um yeah what'd you just say
before newtonian uh
forget bats you can talk about newtonian
physics if you want um he was the one
with the apple right yeah i think i was
talking about
um
oh we're all preparing for a zombie
apocalypse anyways it's it's like what
we're all looking for each other reverse
fantasy about it yeah because we don't
like each other we're not united we're
we're just separate entities we all look
at each other as like cattle yeah that
we have to avoid and everyone's like
i'll probably get it
i can [ __ ] everything i probably won't
be murdered immediately in the street
i'll probably get out of that
yeah
yeah
i don't know if it did coe didn't turn
into a zombie apocalypse so i think
we're probably good
you know
what if it starts attacking our
brains
i was very concerned for a while
that it was going to kill everyone
even like just a couple months ago still
i'm just getting less nervous about it
but i was like maybe it's just gonna
it's a we don't know it's a super weapon
yet or not a weapon but some some sort
of
virus that's gonna learn it's just the
first way of learning us and then it's
just going to keep getting worse and
worse and worse yeah and there's like
some scientists in wuhan who designed it
knows that's going to happen but we just
haven't all figured it out yet but
seems like it's not going to be that i'm
i'm thinking it's going to come back
you think yeah i don't know if it's
going to be deadlier or not but it's
just going to just like be a pain in the
ass it's back in china right now right
yeah
i mean there's more covenant now than
like the fashion history except for that
one big peak
that one big peak yeah we had a big peak
and it's starting to come down but
worldwide it's still bigger than like
all the other peaks right now
yeah i think we're all too everyone's
just burnt out on
everyone's burnt out on it and it's like
this classic thing of
the suffering isn't happening in front
of you so
yeah [ __ ] it you know it's very in the
in your face you know short-term
thinking
um but you know
i uh
yeah i'm worried about it
i definitely think it can come back but
you know we gotta preserve our way of
life and going to applebee's and stuff
yeah i need to we need to keep telling
[ __ ] jokes for
terrible people this is important for
people
so are you still doing jiu jitsu i don't
mean i love those people
um
yeah yeah you know not as a priority in
my life but as my as the extra the
exercise i would say that's the worst
martial art for a zombie apocalypse
because you got to get right on top of
them
yeah
yeah that would suck you're just
honestly i have this theory i've been
trying to do a joke about it for forever
but it's just that every martial arts
and ultimate fighting it's just [ __ ]
because no one trains to attack the
penis or the eyes like if you're
actually
for hundreds of years developing what
the best defensive martial art is for
people it would heavily evolve eye pokes
and like dick pulls there's a lot of jiu
jitsu situations where it's like i'm
just gonna rip your balls off right now
like there's yeah you got me compromised
but um people aren't so it's not even
really close to a real fight yeah um
chimps would have an advantage because
that's all they go for and it's like
what yeah and it's like what is the
scarier thing like this guy has is an
mma fighter who is undefeated or this
guy has been training this guy can rip
your dick off half a second like you can
punch him in the face but he'll rip the
dick off like a charging elephant like
he's really good at like i'll fight he's
a ball collector [ __ ] that guy yeah i'm
not gonna scare everyone's balls yeah
he's got him on the like one of those
native americans just
like how ronda rousey was taking
everyone's arms yeah this guy's faking
balls
he just knows the correct way to posit
his he's got like the perfect body to
get under your yeah a skinny hobo who is
uh a
master at ripping people's dicks off is
much scarier than the most violent ufc
fighter
yeah because it's like permanent it's
like long term
so i do think it's kind of
kind of
useless but it is really fun how did it
get that energy out
no ball reaping yeah i feel like if you
just instead of trained punching if you
were just like
doing that it's like yeah
you have a belt and
it takes me a third of a second to rip
your dick
i don't know yeah that's that's the
worst
one that's what chimps do they go for
the fingers they go for the nose they go
they know what's important to you and
then they take it yeah so joe rogan said
yeah
yeah how was your sling how's your it's
fun i haven't done it in a while it's
hard to find a place to stay now's the
time to attack you not practice
yeah
like if you go to a gym like right after
someone's worked out that's their when
they're the weakest when they have the
least strength right
so smart yeah that's when i attack
people go to the gym a lot
right after on the way out yeah they're
going in
yeah that's not the time they're
probably they're on free when they're on
pre-workout they're well resourced this
time they're amped on their music do not
fight that person
to hope that they didn't forget
something in their car and they're just
popping out real quick yeah
you gotta get them when they're sweaty
yeah you gotta make sure they're sweaty
um this is a real
like skinny boys guy to fighting grab
the balls
and the dick grab the balls and poke
them in there after try and get me in an
arm bar as i destroy your nut sack
take the arm you have my arm i have your
ball take my arm yeah i'm up the panel
you're giving me your
take my arm you're giving me your nuts i
think do that because that's the only
way to do that sport sustainably you
can't keep doing jiu jitsu if you keep
getting your balls yet somebody do any
martial arts sustainably but it's fun
it's just fine to me that it has
manifested pattern than that at the
highest level if you were to take
someone from a different universe who
was just training
and attacking eyes and teeth and nutsack
and you had them fight my money's on
that guy i don't care if you can throw a
punch or not you know yeah a lot of
those techniques are not
going to work out
yeah you can
hit someone's head really hard but not
their balls like i would rather lose my
balls in my head
yeah if you get punched in the head
really hard there's a chance you're
going to be able to keep going you're
gonna punch in the balls really hard
you're sitting down for three like for a
while
yeah
you're uh although you can't reproduce i
would be interested to know the effects
of adrenaline on
getting smacked in the balls really hard
you know what i mean maybe you'll just
anger your opponent like if i kick you
in the balls as hard as i can and then i
shove an epipen in your leg like what is
physically what are you capable of
or does it just make it
way worse that's what isis does to fight
against america they just kick each
other in the balls yeah so that's
terrifying it's like meth during
world war two for the nazis that's very
scary like you if you kick that man in
the balls it makes him more powerful
[ __ ] that guy yeah there's nothing i
could do yeah
um what about women
do they what about one can you just punt
them in the [ __ ] or
they'll get really mad they'll fight you
like you're the patriarchy like how dare
you cat call me they'll be filled with
feminine rage will women
i mean
i think women are probably more
trained to attack the dick more
more
yeah like they're much more aware of the
the true vulnerable spots of a guy if
they need to because it's very real
not some fun fighting thing for them
it's very it's gonna take away their
dick they can't rape you but if they
were fighting each other
[Music]
i think it's still i think probably
getting kicked in the [ __ ] is extremely
painful and as well and you know a good
thing to attack if you're trying if
you're a girl trying to get to another
girl yeah you could [ __ ] up their
reproductive [ __ ] they could you could
block their baby-making and then the
boobs i know are more of a balance
more of a balanced thing but some
professional fighters they get big fake
teddies and they
beat the [ __ ] out of people so maybe not
i don't know yeah it's like a punching
bag yeah would you ever get a fake tip
no
are you lying
no i like small titties i don't like big
titties i mean girls yeah but guys
guys
i don't like this song guys
you don't like tits on guys
no
i have some i bought some tits
guy tits i know i have guide jets yeah i
do i got them for tick tock
guy tetsiri
guy teddy gary yeah guy to yuri
that's the worst snl
i've ever heard of it's guy fiori with
tits it's gotta take your
fire
that's bad even for snl standards
so what do you think about um
the whole uh
you know
austin comedy scene which hole
i love it
yeah
um i think the austin comedy scene
i think it's not
i think when joe first pitched it it was
this like
thing where you thought a bunch of
headliners and huge comedians would come
over here and clearly that's not true at
all there's not you can't compete with
the level of headliners you can see in
in la
or new york but what joe did do by
talking a whole bunch of [ __ ] about his
comedy club on his podcast is um
regardless of the fact that it's not
here yet but everyone at our level
across all of america
opener to 20 minutes or so we all came
here yeah we all came here and it's made
the environment for people at feature
two headliner level that the step below
extremely competitive
in a good way and it's made the
community very poppin and i really
believe in
a lot of the talent here who are our
peers and that's coming from los angeles
when i know the talent they have they
know the up and coming talent and i know
the people here and
the the the current feature level people
in austin easily competitive with l.a
yeah and new york so yeah i really like
i don't think it's the current scene
it's not like
all these headliners all the time like
it is in the in the bigger cities maybe
eventually but not right now well they
visited me a lot of the biggest comics
visit yeah they come through for sure
and once this club opens up it'll be
even they'll have a steady place to go
yeah and it'll be a great audience but
i'm saying i almost don't even care like
i like it's good and important
to see
for me to see really high level comedy
but i'm more concerned about being in a
scene and having peers that i believe in
yeah is comics and i have that yeah it's
a good scene because it's not corrupted
like l.a or new york it's not just like
for the headliners to parasitize to
further their career at the expense of
the
other
other comedians and it's pure it's like
people that actually just want to do
comedy they don't want to like people
who want to do comedy right yeah
passionate enough about it to chan to
move cities
blindly and it's i mean i could name i
mean there's i'm very happy with like
who our friends are yeah you know
they're [ __ ] good yeah highly
original and fun and they have a joy to
it that i don't think people in la and
new york have anymore yeah and that's
just started starting to cauter like i
really am enjoying the vibe a year out
being able to go i mean isn't it so
amazing like
compared to where especially for you but
just compared to where i was a year ago
the fact that i can go out
to clubs and bars here and walk in and
see comics who are
there's just a community now and
everyone's starting to get closer and
get better
and push each other in the way that's
i'm happy with yeah yeah
yeah it's a great scene i think it's
great for developing their no clubs
but
developing for developing it's amazing
yeah i mean that's also covered too i
think like cap city had to shut down
yeah they
have they were supposed to open in
february so it's all a mirage to me now
but i know the point doesn't care about
anymore because we're all getting better
regardless yeah and um
you i mean it doesn't even matter for
you because you're
getting you have the what the club would
have provided you mean you already have
access to that it's like
yeah
i would love to have the club and then
have like a ten minute spot you know
maybe two or three every day
at the club it i mean
that was the
that's what the
in the best version of what austin could
be
it could for comedians it could be you
could walk to four sets in a night yeah
conceivably
especially when these clubs open which
would be amazing yeah it's not quite
like that
but it it could be once they open
yeah i'm really excited about it uh i
think it's so beautiful and so pure and
so beautiful so pure
it's not like l.a or new york which i
thought was the only options and i'm so
glad that another thing opened up
yeah well i'm i
like have a natural pushback to the la
slander because i'm from that like i'm
from there and my dad's from there i
love los angeles but i
have a very different experience of los
angeles than a lot of people do and also
right now it's [ __ ] crazy it is
actually
really bad over there but i agree austin
is
the place to be for stand up right now
and there is the
the people who came here there is a
a joy
yeah a joy and lightheartedness which is
very refreshing yeah they're happy to
have this this was taken away from us
and yeah yeah and the real yeah real
comedians yeah really passionate about
comedy where
i think in big cities you get a lot of
people
yeah you know yeah actors trying it out
yeah half-assing it they're like i might
as well do something with my life that's
one of the things yeah that they do
they're not like i will die if i don't
do standard it's just like let me try
doing stand up yeah they do it in a pure
way and it's like speaks to them and
they scratch an itch with it as opposed
to just like you know hobbyist
yeah
i don't know
yeah i'm stoked about it yeah yeah how
about you i'm i'm having a great time
you know i bet you [ __ ] i want to
keep doing it smooching
smooching away
yeah
i mean i guess i gotta do those kill
tony's more i gotta start
have you done it before i've waited a
couple of times but i've never gotten
done chosen yeah you'd do great there
it's good it would be good for my yeah
for my style probably but it's
i just need to buy tickets i've gone a
couple times you don't like standing i'm
not gonna let people
put me in a kennel you don't have to
stand in the kennel
well it's like outside or in the kennel
oh yeah you don't want to stand outside
no i just want to be treat like
no i'm not gonna
subject myself i'm not i just won't do
that i'll spy taking go i know it's
really important and
um
i just know it's really important that
it's
like a really good show but
i've done a couple times and haven't
gotten up i'm like i'm not gonna do this
again i'll buy a ticket
and just sit at a table yeah it's sort
of
dehumanizing
yeah and comics will let themselves be
dehumanized early on yeah
in a way that i'm not
like okay well for yourself i guess yeah
you don't want to uh you know be
trod trotted trot in a pound but i think
that's also a very comedian it surprises
me that comedians look i'm not saying
this is what's happening with kill tony
but comedians let themselves get pushed
around a little bit at times and it
strikes me as a very anti-comedy thing
in some ways you know they're supposed
to be sticking out it should be
resistant yeah i feel like comics have a
natural resistance to authority as
opposed to that
but it makes sense because you're
subjecting yourself to so much emotional
trauma and you're bombing and you're
like yeah
doing as many mics as possible
um
and like you know that's like the path
that a lot of like actors or
entertainers have to face is like the
humiliating auditions and
yeah and you want something so bad
like yeah if you have a chance at it
here you'll do whatever you want you
mean i got to play around for a living i
would love to do that yeah and they'd
sacrifice anything in the beginning to
get that yeah and if you think it's
gonna help 100
yeah yeah
but uh yeah i mean i think it's uh
it could be a great thing are we
wrapping up this podcast sure is that
the vibe that's going on yeah
whatever this podcast
whatever this podcast is whatever this
channel is
unreleased
unreleased dude i'm sorry we snapped at
you in the beginning it wasn't even
funny
you should incorporate him better
um nice so i'm excited to sign this
waiver again that'll be fine
you got any plugs
[Music]
in the studio check out the able app
they were like it's a like reddit meets
tick tock meets facebook i was like it's
not gonna work out for you
guys it's like a
alternative to twitter so if you don't
like elon buying twitter
check out abel that was probably
actually probably pretty bad for them
yeah i think twitter probably not good
for him actually
and the people here are great yeah
all right do you have you do your
signature sign off
hey
no that's the beginning
bye